[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: You've read a million
articles about this by now.
A tiny minority of Americans
own a shockingly huge chunk
of the country's wealth.
Bernie Sanders,
progressive campaigner
and presidential
hopeful, proposes
something that often gets
a pretty polarizing label,
redistribution, taking from
the rich and giving the poor.
The media loves to compare
Sanders and his tax plan
to Robin Hood.
Actually, so do his supporters.
And the Robin Hood
comparison really
captures the two views
on income redistribution.
Either it's populist and
heroic, or it's thievery.
ROBIN HOOD: Tyranny makes
men do desperate things.
NARRATOR: However you
feel about Bernie or Robin
Hood, the idea of
redistribution,
it's about a lot
more than taxation.
It's really about waste.
Let's look at prescription
drugs for a minute.
Americans spend about
$270 billion each year
on prescription meds.
And to overuse an expression,
that's billion with a B. Health
care costs in general have
been on the rise for some time,
and that's made access to
medicine trickier and trickier.
A New York Times poll last year
found that 1 in 4 Americans
didn't fill a
prescription they needed,
because it was too expensive.
But there's another stat
worth mentioning here.
About 3% of all that
medicine is wasted.
Extra meds are stockpiled
by manufacturers,
and then discarded
once they've expired.
Or commonly, patients
change medications and toss
out there remaining
stock of the old meds.
3% may not sound like
a lot, but that adds up
to $8.1 billion dollars wasted.
And given that 1 in 4
Americans aren't always
getting the meds they
need, that's a big deal.
And that is where
redistribution comes in.
More and more
programs are popping
that collect unused medication
before it expires, and provides
the meds to those in need.
One state-run
program in Oklahoma
has been at it since 2004,
recycling millions of dollars
in medication, and his
cost taxpayers just $6,000
to do it all.
There's even a nonprofit website
called Sirum that matches meds
with safety net clinics, who
then dispense them to patients.
Experts call this
medicine recycling.
But the media loves to talk
about in terms of-- well,
you guessed it.
ROBIN HOOD: We're sort
of a collection agent.
NARRATOR: And this idea
isn't limited to medicine.
One of the founders of Trader
Joe's made headlines this year
by opening Daily Table, a
nonprofit grocery store.
Daily Table collects foods that
wholesalers would otherwise
throw out because they're
surplus or expiring soon,
and then sells them to low
income communities for cheap--
which sounds an awful lot
like medicine recycling.
They're matching surplus
goods with those who don't
have a secure access to them.
The larger point here
is that medicine, food,
and other markets
aren't 100% efficient.
We're better at
creating resources
than we are at getting
them to the people, which
is a problem that
redistribution can help fix.
That's Bernie Sanders' point,
when it comes to wealth.
It's not reaching the
people who need it.
This starts to feel
more Robin Hood-y,
and again, you might
not agree with it.
But whatever you think
about income redistribution,
it's worth thinking about
the idea of redistribution
in general, because
we'll probably still
be talking about it after this
election is long since past.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
If you want more
videos like this one,
check out this episode on
how a chicken, of all things,
caused a huge conflict between
the federal government,
environmentalists, and Big Oil.
SPEAKER (VOICEOVER):
But it's worth
mentioning here that the
habitat we're talking about,
the fabled American prairie,
is full of a lot more than just
prairie chickens.
There are prairie dogs, sand
dune lizards, swift foxes,
burrowing owls, and the
rest of a very carefully
balanced ecosystem.
NARRATOR: And don't
forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]